welcome to this video it is the respect
tiger who is that tar Hirohito yeah what
can i play what is offbeat huh I have
gwent for g6 maybe I should really think
about this beforehand some kind of some
kind of benoni maybe this one that
that's really dicey ok he goes for a
form it's a bit strong against the gym
he really knows some theory here it
seems I know that this is a line and I
don't know more I don't study openings
like that usually I just know that this
is in existence and g5 you go age 6 that
looks terrible on the light squares yeah
wow what do what do you what a precision
maybe I should have played something a
little bit more a little bit more solid
anyway it's six possible takes on e6 I
have g5 that's not too bad I hope night
efore d5 yes is that possible that could
be quite good actually not sure it looks
very very strange obviously this
position but ok I can take here that
sets that's really okay and deform so
I'm winning taking this and I have Queen
edge formerly Queen edge form and Bishop
g4 why just Bishop takes d5 which is
this is just a pawn up right but Queen a
twin edge for strong jets play that that
must be better actually
to like steak here spoiling his castling
and cannot be cannot be bad so let's go
here wow it's really a great position
against the GM what does he doing maybe
queenie to Queenie 5 something like that
no that's blundering stuff yeah okay I
want to develop quickly let's do this
and for castling short what now Queen to
h4 is this good it looks good right
let's do that check using the pin and
Queen g3 next so if I take with the
bishop and Queen g3 how is he saving
that I guess he isn't wow what a
disaster
Jim what what was wrong here for him d6
probably not sure but cattle is giving
up the Queen down um yeah so a chica
take here yeah just 97 I was just taking
a moment to see if there's any kind of
trick but I don't don't don't see it
let's see you use all the pieces for the
attack don't don't I shouldn't try to to
win technically just try to checkmate
them
yeah maybe here taking that
Queen g5 next I probably wasn't the
easiest way to do it but I think it
should be enough
Knight f3 is the threat to end the whole
thing white eyes I guess before I could
play that yeah it's probably a bit
frustrating a 444 GM to lose like that
after that against this weird opening
but I don't know I really don't know i
think if voice is a line definitely but
I don't know if g4s right I think it is
dumb yeah I went six and probably
something else now yeah this is better
he plays that here h3y a white is
probably just better somehow after that
after D is 65 it's basically basically
over and h3 really is better and okay
still if he takes a half g five maybe I
can play like this for night before or
something
huh I don't know it's good it's stranger
it's very strange chess 96 sound
interesting maybe I can take here check
it's very weird that looks very
dangerous for black looks very dangerous
yeah it is probably am probably really
what what he plated is d 6 is almost
giving it away I think looks very
problematic already i will get that pawn
and then black has a big center all of a
sudden and g4 looks completely out of
place the relatively best line that the
engine is giving is it is but what is
this I mean this is white is a pawn down
yeah that's that's very important to
note what has white needs to show comp
for porn and this is really not the case
i have a huge center yeah amazing this
is this weird opening struck it's by the
way it's called the claret clarendon
court variation very weird but yeah
chlorine can you go in there it's just
it's just rubbish a while it's just lost
here amazing so that funky opening
struck the problem with this kind of
opening this it is it is sometimes good
for one game but whenever you play
someone who really suspects that you
play this kind of stuff they will look
it up and and find something it's just
just too shaky and he probably knew it
up to this but now yeah he got into
problems but next time he will know what
to do and yeah it's probably not a good
idea to repeat it okay well thanks for
watching